[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my top Randall can you see me
lady gaga arrives first middle in the
ultimate cap she has a 45 dancers behind
her she's giving ultimate camp she's the
queen of camp and a co-chair tonight
every detail of what she's wearing is
pretty pink like the carpet if it's a a
triple moment with Lady gaga at the Met
you look amazing
Lady Gaga as you can see behind her five
dancers to hold the veils they've got
the umbrellas and every once in a while
they'll give you a little bit of life
and pop that train up
[Music]
there is an entirely choreographed
routine here at the Met Gala everyone is
perfect is that dancers are perfect the
train is choreographed it is so well
thought out we're taking you inside all
the camp fashion at the Met Gala
including Lady Gaga's this is an
extravaganza even for Lady gaga
[Applause]
[Music]
what and now a costume change is
happening
[Music]
and now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
lady gaga is now removing the pink
jacket there's clearly something
underneath I don't know that we've ever
seen a costume change like this at the
Met Gala she now is taking it off the
shoulders a full beside hers are a
longtime collaborator Brandon Maxwell
he's got his golden scissors I know and
now she's changing and underneath
[Applause]
what and the skirts come on a photograph
20 on the red carpet
[Music]
[Applause]
lady gaga the queen of theatrics the
queen of camp is giving us a fully
choreographed routine on the Met Gala
stairs right now this is her second
costume change and I believe there is a
third underneath
how many hours did this take you and
then
this way
I've been covering the Met Gala for many
years and I have never seen a fully
choreographed entrance like this so big
every moment is perfect
okay I think there's going to be a third
costume change
he's cutting so Brandon's cutting the
dress off of Lady Gaga right now it
looks like he's cutting it off what
could be underneath something pink
[Applause]
there's another third dress he's now
pulling the straps out and adding them
to her look this is so major this is so
major
lady gaga
[Music]
[Music]
now Gaga has brought out her cellphone
her lipstick her glam squad and
she has her own paparazzi honestly I
don't need to see anything else
who's on the phone Gaga isn't Bradley
are you reuniting for another movie
there's got to be another outfit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fourth outfit for sure you can tell
because she's a bodysuit
[Music]
bodysuit right
yes come here
how many hours how many hours of
rehearsal and down she goes again to the
beginning of the carpet for what I think
is going to be a fourth costume change
[Music]
so they like
no pulling a wagon in no it's okay so in
Lady Gaga's wagon it looks like she's
got champagne some hats a clutch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ugly
gaga whose idea was the costumed oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yes Gaga working yes
get a girl that's how an Oscar winner
comes to the Met Gala babies yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]